NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAL BARRIGA: Hi, I'm Sal.
Today, we're going to solve
Problem 8 of the Final Exam of
2009 for 3.091.
The problem reads as follows.
The phospholipid--
the chemical formula
is right here--
is added to hexane--
which is C6H14, which
is a hydrocarbon--
in sufficient quantities to
enable interaction between
phospholipid molecules.
Draw a cartoon depicting one
possible molecular arrangement
that results.
You may stylize your parts of
the phospholipid molecule with
the squiggly line-- which
is shown in the exam--
for a hydrocarbon chain.
So if we look at our molecule
here, the first thing that we
want to understand is what
the structure is.
And as you can see, the molecule
has a nonpolar
component and it has
a polar component.
So for the problem, it will be
good to isolate the two with
different colors, and then we'll
stylize them such that
the nonpolar part is the zigzag
line and the polar
component is the red circle.
So we want to go ahead and draw
the arrangement together
when it's added to hexane.
So the easiest thing to do
is to draw a picture.
So we come over here
to the right.
And this is part a.
I'm going to draw a beaker
with hexane.
And I know that as soon as I
look at my chemical formula
for hexane--
which is C6H14 and is
a hydrocarbon--
I know that it's nonpolar.
So I know from my knowledge of
3.091, when chemical bonding,
that like dissolves like.
So the molecules that are polar
are going to want to
stick together, and molecules
that are nonpolar are going to
want to stick together.
So by looking at my
phospholipid, I
already know that--
the problem tells me that--
I'm adding a sufficient amount
such that the molecules can
interact with each other.
So the only thing that comes to
mind for me that will be a
possible arrangement,
would be that--
in the hexane, which is
nonpolar, and if we have a
distribution of these
phospholipid molecules--
then one possible arrangement
will be that you have a bunch
of your polar heads interacting
together with the
hydrocarbon components out here
interacting with the hexane.
Because the hydrocarbon
component again is nonpolar.
The hexane is nonpolar.
So those want to interact
with each other.
But the polar component,
which are the
heads for the molecule--
the phospholipid
as a molecule--
are going to go ahead and
interact with each other.
And pretty much if you were to
write this down on the exam,
you would get full points
for part a.
Now we'll move on to part b.
Part b says, to the beaker
described in part a, an equal
volume of liquid ammonia--
NH3--
is added.
The mixture of hexane-NH3--
or ammonia containing
the phospholipid--
is now subjected to vigorous
agitation for several minutes
and then allowed
to equilibrate.
Draw a schematic representation
depicting one
possible molecular arrangement
that results.
The values of density are 0.65
grams per centimeter cubed for
hexane and 0.6 grams
per centimeter
cubed for liquid ammonia.
Assume that hexane and liquid
ammonia are mutually
immiscible.
So there's a lot of
information within the paragraph.
And the first thing that it
gives us is the densities
between the two components.
It tells us they're immiscible,
so immiscibility
means that they're
not going to mix.
The question that you want to
answer now is, which layer is
going to be at the top?
Which layer is going to
be at the bottom?
Well, the more dense layer
should be at the bottom, and
the more dense happens
to be hexane.
So if I go ahead and draw my
beaker again for part b, and
then I mix my components.
And now I have two components
that are separated by an
immiscible boundary.
And I know that the density of
hexane is given by 0.65 grams
per centimeter cubed.
And the density of
liquid ammonia--
which is NH3--
is given as 0.60 grams
per centimeter cubed.
So I know that the hexane is
going to be down here, so I'll
go ahead and label this C6H14.
And I'll label this as NH3.
So one important thing to
know is, what is the
structure of ammonia?
Well, we know that
ammonia happens
to be a polar molecule.
And its structure is simply
given by-- you have a central
nitrogen atom, and you have
three hydrogens and a lone
pair of electrons-- and the lone
pair of electrons is what
gives the ammonia
the structure.
Hence, you have a polar dipole
moment on your molecule.
The fact that this is polar
means that it's going to
interact with the polar head of
your phospholipid molecule.
And we already know we have
hexane plus your phospholipid.
Well, if in our arrangement with
the absence of ammonia
the heads group together because
that was the only
polar component in the mixture,
then over here I
should expect the heads to
rearrange themselves such that
they are in contact
with the ammonia.
So one possible arrangement for
the system would be that I
would have my polar part of my
molecule interacting with the
ammonia, and the hydrocarbon
chain interacting--
which is the nonpolar
component-- interacting with
the nonpolar mixture.
So if you were to draw this
schematic, then you would get
full points on the
exam as well.
So that's again, like
dissolves like.
And if you fully understand
the nature of secondary
bonding, then this problem
shouldn't be that difficult to
go through.
Now there's a final part to this
problem, which is part c.
And part c says, to the beaker
described in part b, a small
amount of iodine--
I2--
is added to the mixture, and
then subjected to vigorous
agitation for several minutes,
and then allowed to
equilibrate.
Explain what you expect
to observe.
Again, we're going on this whole
issue of like dissolves
like, or that polar molecules
want to be with polar
molecules because they should
be miscible together.
And we are given that now
we're going to add I2--
iodine.
Well, iodine is a linear
molecule that's nonpolar.
There are no other atoms that
are bonded to it that can give
any polarity.
So if I was to go ahead and draw
this diagram, the first
thing that comes to my mind is
that the iodine should mix
with the hexane, because
essentially it's a nonpolar
component mixing with another
nonpolar component.
So if I draw my diagram, I'm
going to go ahead and draw the
two immiscible regions.
And one question that a lot of
students have is, how do you
know that the iodine
is not going to be
on top of the ammonia?
Well, iodine is pretty dense.
It's actually more dense than
these two molecules over here.
So the fact that it's more
dense, I know it's going to
want to sit at the bottom
where the other nonpolar
molecule is at.
So I would argue that down here
we would have hexane--
C6H14--
mixed with iodine.
Over here, we will still
have our ammonia.
And then our polar heads
would still be--
the polar part of the
phospholipid molecule will be
in contact or bonding
with the ammonia.
And the nonpolar tail would be
with the nonpolar components
which are hexane and iodine.
So if you did this on the exam,
you get full points.
And being able to fully
understand secondary bonding
will help you solve
this problem in no
less than 10 minutes.
So that's it.